gentleman with the slightly lighter
colored hair um
it's a polite way of saying the older
man
are you a fan of hip-hop
victorian
not really i want to convince you so if
you could hear a hip-hop song of
anything in the world what would it be
about
donald trump what about specifically
where people are very upset with you
i'm gonna come back to that okay
um someone over here said victorian
something
what was it
you're covering your face which means it
was you what did you say victorian what
was it was something you blurted out and
now you regret i don't understand
is that are you all okay everyone
so reticent
victorian century rap
okay yeah no
we shouldn't serve this lady any more
alcohol
okay victorian wrap that's a good
suggestion i like that
no don't be embarrassed that was a good
suggestion my gosh i feel please
be okay
back of the room what would you like a
rap about that
you said
you're shouting bleeker street and the
other person's shouting a haberdasher so
okay the bleeker street haberdashery
victorian rap so far guys
you're coming up with words that are too
long for that woman to pronounce
let's come over here what would you guys
like to rap about
going in because i've said full skin
that feels obvious what did she say
going antique shopping
aren't you all such a prim and proper
bunch
what are you on the hunt for while
you're antiquing
lamps antique lamps of course you are
antique shopping for lamps and bleaker
street haberdashery victorian rap um
people over here hello what would you
like a rap about
it
you said donald duck and you said wiley
coyote
here we go
different different universes but i'm
sure we can bring them together donald
duck and wiley coyote antique shopping
for lamps blinker street haberdashery
and victorian rap now my friend we came
to you first um we disappointed you with
donald trump but we've got donald ducks
that's close what what have we what have
we decided
to rap about
yeah
daffy duck
okay
i feel like the show is going to go on
too long if i'm like no we need
something else fine
so wiley coyote versus daffy duck
oblique street haberdashery antique
shopping the victorian rat and daffy
duck
this then lovely people
what's this discussion going on here
okay um
pennsylvania dutch
yeah
is that what you're saying yeah cool the
pennsylvania dutch maybe we'll throw
those in as well
[ __ ] hell right
this is a freestyle a rat made up on the
spot not rent the amish okay thank you
for clarifying
i think they're different people really
um
they look the same uh this is gonna be a
wrap and and red and jeremy they prove
themselves to be such magnificent
musicians throughout the show and their
careers and they're going to lay down
some sweet sweet beets for us to have
some tasty treats so let's do that
[Applause]
[Music]
feel that base that's vibrating through
my buttocks
nice
it took a while for my man on the side
when i asked he he was like dt now he's
saying daffy that's a dd like a cup size
daffy duck looking different to donald
he provides
mainly just the black feathers pull it
all together like a white ring at the
neck looking clever pretty smart pretty
suave like a doc james bond that's the
daffy there if i see him on the dot cons
maybe he got an entourage maybe followed
by the guy in the sailor suit that's
donald why is he wearing no pants with
the white feather i like the little top
hat it's kind of not leather but fabric
and if he sees mickey's like yo donald
would you come quickly donald can't
speak but daffy can so maybe he's got
the linguistic skills of a man but
donald's like
i don't know how to do the voice and
wiley coyote road runner not by choice
he's just driven an insane urge for
getting that horrible fast-legged bird
why are we usually on the side of road
runner i like the guy with explosives
much funner he drops an anvil but obama
it crushes him down like oppressive heat
in the summer and this thing yo we
should keep in touch i'm a fan of
pennsylvania i'm loving the dutch
they're coming over from holland and
rotterdam in amsterdam and saying we be
coming over here what's the plan to
build a big barn how you like me now
patton's on the side milking all the cow
one day i really get my wish no one
should ever confuse us with amish they
don't understand they're like it's not
right they'd be frightened if they saw
tonight with the lights whoa these
should be done by candles lit from
flattering angles or maybe take a chance
with the lamp ashore there a amish
lampkanda la brea i'll be on the little
alleyways and i'm seeking i'm looking
for the right lamps when i'm antiquing i
know how you feel the lamp that i love i
look down there i stoop from above i get
the other shoppers out the way and i
shove but then it's got one of those
[ __ ] old plugs how am i gonna use this
the plug's whack i can't get a
modernizer thing to adapt it won't fit
in the wall it won't fit in a socket and
so i just put it in my pocket then i
rock it out the door and the guy's so
elderly he chased me down the street but
he fell for me shattered his femur and
his thighs and all the rest his pelvis
this was pioneer by yeah i should tell
this i'm seeking antiquing on street
that be bleaking if you want a nice
cloak you and me speaking i'll be
walking in want a cut that's flattering
for me i go hello taylor the
haberdashery is open and i've spoken
with the chap he says yo chris put this
on your back i'm like yo that's not the
way you expect to be greeted but still i
look good in my saturn i seek it take it
home for my wardrobe it's not whack but
200 years ago wore mainly black why my
husband died and now i'm adoring you
what's the name not a mules name queen
victoria see me here yes i am the queen
everybody else now you fools are obscene
i'm the queen upon the throne ruling for
the longest time nobody's got garters
that are longer than mine i don't like
seeing legs and ankles don't like seeing
it yo i can't scan your queen victoria
yes drop the wraps into your what we
going to do next invade india
[Applause]